In this problem, we ask you to implement Euclid's algorithm using JavaScript.
We're not expecting you to be a JavaScript guru,
but it's useful to know the basic constructs when we're developing our interpreter for it.
Perhaps, the best way to get familiar is by programming something.
Euclid's algorithm is incredibly simple.
It computes the GCD, or the greatest common divisor.
Let's call our function gcd. It takes 2 inputst that are integers--a and b.
If a = b, we're going to return a.
If a > b, we're going to calculate the gcd of a - b and b.
Taking a step back, this first one made sense.
If you're given 2 numbers--36 and 36--it's pretty clear that the greatest common divisor is 36.
So we're just going to pick 1. It could have been b, it doesn't really matter.
This next one may not be as clear, but you probably have some intuition why it's true.
We're going to reserve a proof for it for an algebra class that you might take
in college or in high school.
If a is less than b, we're going to calculate gcd of a and b - a.
So looking at all of this together, it kind of looks like pseudocode,
and actually it looks very close to the code that we're going to write
be it in Python or JavaScript.
So let's get right to it, and I'll go over some of the JavaScript notations and conventions
as I code this up.
But really this is it.
So to declare a JavaScript function, we use the keyword function,
and then the name of a function, which we call gcd.
We're going to take in 2 inputs--a and b.
Now we have our function body.
Unlike Python where we can just use tabbing and whitespace to indicate
what parts of the code are blocks or subparts of the rest of the code,
we use braces, and forgive my poor bracing technique.
I've never gotten very good at this.
Now the first thing we're going to do is an if--if a = b, we're going to return a.
If you haven't already figured it out, this is a recursive definition,
and we're going to use it to write a recursive function.
If a = b, we're going to return a, just like we've said.
Oh yeah, and don't forget your semicolons just like I just did.
Otherwise, else.
If a > b, we're going to do gcd of a - b and b.
Always add your semicolon. Finish your brace.
We have 1 last case. Another else, and we're done.